let's get a stl window going on linux so
i'm on a debian version of linux this is
mx linux
super free super uh awesome uh go get it
if you don't have it or use whatever
linux you currently have so we have a
terminal
and uh what we're gonna do here is just
go
sudo apt-get install live sdl to
dev okay so that's the main requirement
we've already got installed but you'll
have
you'll go through the install if you
don't have installed so the next thing
we want to do is just create a directory
i'm going to change directory into my
project
and i'm just going to make your maker
sdl
to uh demo so then i'm just going to go
into there
cl2 demo and i'm just going to open this
with an editor you can use whatever
editor you want i'm just going to use
visual studio code
so here we are with a fresh instance of
visual studio
code and a new project just an empty
folder let's go ahead and make a folder
just called src for source so i'm going
to do cmake here
and cmake has a quick start so we'll
just click that
and use our gcc compiler and our name
for the new project this is
sdl to a demo
and this can be either a library or an
executable in our case we're going to do
an executable
so there we go it gives us c test and
cpac and all that stuff going
we are going to not use
c test comment that out i'm going to
comment out enable testing i'm going to
comment out
the set cpac stuff because we're not
going to be installing anything we just
want to run
this gives us a really basic
project with an executable and a main
here
we're going to actually move our main
into source
yes please so let's just make sure it
runs
so i'm going to hit f7 here and
basically just run the cmake stuff and
press f5 to run
yeah that's fine yeah okay
this is this is more of what we wanted
it's uh named sdl2 demo it doesn't have
a dot out or anything sdl2
underscore of course
build folder and then sdl2
demo
yeah that should work and we should see
like a hello world or a little terminal
down here
there it is hello world okay we should
be able to make a window now [ __ ]
getting a window going is actually uh
pretty easy i'm not going to type all
the code manually instead i'm just going
to open
google chrome i'm going to just search
in google for sdl2 window uh
tutorial so basically i just don't want
to have to retype the code over because
there we go all right so as you can see
there's some code here
we're basically just going to grab this
and we'll just copy it all and i'm just
going to paste it in here
and just with that we should be able to
reconfigure recompile and run it
says it doesn't see sdl okay now this is
not where it is it's just where it is on
their demo
but for us it is
right there so we'll
try to rebuild and see what it says and
it's going to have a link or error
because it's not linked
to the library so it's going to say
undefined reference
um yeah so it sees the headers
but it doesn't see it doesn't it just
doesn't know where the library is
basically
so we have to tell it that in our cmake
i'll get rid of the cpac stuff and see
test make a little cleaner
we just need to do let's see target
link libraries
sdl2 demo is the target
and we want to link it to uh but it
doesn't say anything about the linker
here what you need to do to link so
let's just do a real quick let's do a
window
sdl2 link
he's got it yeah here it is says cl2
main
so we don't need this l in c make if
you're manually putting the line
like they're doing on that then you do
but i'm just going to use
sdl to main and lsdl2
it'll automatically do the rest because
uh
cmake does that for us so now we'll
rebuild it and we should get a
successful build here at this point
and when we hit f5 we should get a
window popping up
from that sample code f5 to run
pressed it twice but hopefully it
doesn't bug anything out there we go we
got in a stale window and see if we can
find some interesting
demos uh let's see like sdl to
uh demo code and see if we can find
something cool
the most common thing to do is either
get some 2d graphics going
like uh this guy from let's make games
has a little tutorial where basically
you get started
just like so you get a window going and
then you can start doing stuff
uh there's a lot of them up here
let's go uh linux uh opengl
sdl to demo
here we go so let's look at this code
and observe it
and yeah there we go
there we go now if we press f we should
get some full screen toggling doesn't
look like that's happening
not sure why but
uh it does move around and now we can
try to resize the window here and see
what happens nope just drags around
so there's some oddities going around
here
[Music]
okay well i stepped away for a while and
i worked on this and got it working
up to a proper demo because that code i
was just looking at from that random
repo
is uh well it doesn't work so here is an
actual working
version uh so i'll show you it first and
then
there we go uh go ahead and
update the build and then run it
okay so basically what i added is i
fixed the full screen i set it to the
f11 key because i think that makes a lot
more sense so i have a lab and
puts it into full screen like so i know
just bright and pink right now
and i also set f10 to resize and flip
between window
sizes so i only got two window sizes
supported but something i learned about
stl as was doing some research is
it does not support on the fly resizing
so there's no dragging edges of the
window with
sdl that is just something that is not
supported
because of a bug and i did link to the
stack overflow of someone else talking
about that somewhere in here so it's in
the code
and the code is now going to be linked
below in a github recover so you don't
have to listen to me flap through all
this
you can just thumbs up this video and go
look at that code but i'm going to walk
through it all so that you can
understand it too
and uh so here we go i will
just start from the top i guess and i
will explain everything let's go ahead
and stop the current code
so everything else is mostly the same i
did add this uh resize callback this is
optional though as i'll talk about
basically this is just a
thing that just notifies you that you're
resizing but you could actually put some
functionality in here but i was just
doing this to test
something so don't worry about this
resize too much unless you want to play
around with it
so as usual we declare a window i
i just use this underscore
between words syntax for everything kept
everything in a main
just to keep it simple so of course we
got our window that is currently a null
pointer and we have our window flags
just uh opengl so we're going to be
using
just an old version of opengl to get
started here
if i go further with this i'll make it
cooler with opengl
but for now it's just uh just about
getting the window
base going and kind of getting a
like an empty window state ready for you
so of course we try to initialize the
video make sure it doesn't fail
if it does we uh print out the error and
return this
this should never happen basically and
we have some initial window sizes we're
going to hold our window sizes
that way we can as i talked about a
little bit earlier just keep
the viewport and the screen size matched
up so these are just the initial sizes
and they're not const because we want to
be able to resize our window
now this enum class screen size is
basically just the supported window
sizes
now usually what games do is they have
like a settings menu or an options menu
and you can flip between the screen
sizes
so that's what you can do and if you
want to add more support for more sizes
you can just
expand this logic now since it does have
a full screen
we want to hold the current screen size
and the last non-full screen size so
when you go to full screen you
well we wanted to remember what it was
before it was full screen so that's why
we have this last non full screen size
so we just start holding two screen
sizes
basically we always operate off the
current one but when we go into full
screen
and we flip back we don't want it to do
some awkward thing we want to go back
how it was before so that's why we hold
the old one
and of course we create the window as
before i gave it a little more useful
title
basically just tells you what the hot
keys are because that's just a really
simple way
right in the title the window tells you
if claiming is full screen
f10 it goes to well when resize and
escape quits so
now when we run it we just you know we
can see that you probably saw it earlier
so that's all basically about the same
and yeah there it is and now when we
close it actually closes
uh so this add event watch is just a
cool thing you can do
for events uh you can you can set a
function so this function
has to exactly match
that's this signature that's the word i
was looking for
um yeah let's keep going so that's just
something you can do
to uh have it do something anytime you
resize the window but this doesn't work
as you would think
i'll talk about that in a minute so i
also set some gl attributes these are
actually optional because we're not
rendering anything with opengl
right now but we will need them later so
i went ahead and put them in there and
it's just opengl 2.1 a pretty
old version of opengl but it's something
where we can play around a little bit
we're not going to get the highest
performance out of it we're not worried
about that right now
we can get into that if if people are
really interested
in this series continuing i will talk
more about that
at a later time but that's uh beyond the
scope here so of course we set the
context to
a gl create context text um
yeah to our window wow i really
butchered that sentence
but that's the same as before too
uh this is our background and the gl
clear color and the viewport here is
setting
the size of the gl so this is the actual
uh
opengl stuff gl clear color gl viewport
and now uh before we go into our main
loop i went ahead and declared a few
variables that we're going to need
for our main loop specifically which is
our is running
so we know when to exit we can use
within our logic we can set this to
false at any time to exit
out of the game out of the loop and stl
event
i just renamed it to lowercase sdl event
just to make it really obvious
what it is
and that's what we're going to need for
processing stuff within our loop so we
enter our main while loop and the first
thing we do is we check if there's any
events now if there's no events
um so if it's uh not equal to zero
we go into here but if it is equal to
zero then we just skip past this so this
is only if you're pressing keys
resizing the window if you're doing
something then it checks what you're
doing basically
and then now the very first thing this
is where the previous code was really
messed up that guy had it all foo barred
to be honest so first thing it does is
it's uh see if you quit and if you quit
it just sets is running
to zero which i'd prefer to have false
here since it's a boolean
directly and it's just a little more
clear if
we're sending it to zero they might
think it's an integer or something it's
just easier to read as false
now this is where i was playing around
with the window resized and then i found
out you basically can't
resize on the fly but if you could this
was
would be how it would be so if you're
interested in an on the fly resize where
you can drag the edges of the window
you should probably use glfw and i can
talk more about glfw in another video if
there's interest but it's basically
another windowing option
um but really we can uh probably just
delete this at this point
i'm just kind of leaving it here for
i got checked in and in one code base so
i'll go ahead and delete it
for the next check in because it's just
not necessary
so okay if we quit we false else if if
we're we have some kind of key down then
we check what the key down
is now we do have escape is quit so
that's another thing
that says is running to false which i'm
just going to go ahead and change here
so um in f11
is going to be the thing that toggles to
full screen so we're using
that enum that we're talking about
earlier here
uh where is she she's up here that just
holds these three different values is
the 640 is 1366 or full screen
that is just that enum
so we're just doing some logic here
basically this whole set of logic says
hey if the current size is not full
screen when you press f11 then go ahead
and save whatever it currently is while
it's not full screen
and then set it to full screen and then
call this sdl set window to full screen
to do the thing
and uh so if that executes it then goes
to the end here and it gets the window
size
and sets the viewport to the window size
so at the end of each of these window
resizing
we do get the new window size and we
adjust the viewport
now since we're kind of repeating this
code we could sort of put this in a
function but anytime we resize the
window we basically want to do this
so the else case here is if it's already
full screen
then we want to set the current size
back to the last non-full screen size
and then do the thing set window full
screen and it's basically no
just no flag a full screen anymore so
it'll just go
back to the hold size when it gets to
here
it will get the new window size that is
not full screen anymore and set the
viewport
so f11 just does a nice nice toggle of
full screen with that logic
and f10 toggles screen sizes and
it notably does nothing if you're full
screen so this switch is on your current
screen size if you're on full screen
size it just doesn't break
it just does nothing it will still
execute this get window size and give
viewport which it actually doesn't need
to do if it's full screen
so that's a little bit of broken code so
it'd probably be a little better like
this to be honest but it's more lines of
code so that's why i didn't have it like
that but
let's just do it like that that's fine
whatever since there is a case where we
don't need to do it
let's do that so uh if your current
screen size
is the 640 then it toggles it to the
other one now this is just some
janky logic to be honest it's uh it
could be much improved but it just
toggles basically between
these two sizes if it's not full screen
and so you have f11 and f10
so like i said before and just a
reminder these would generally be
in the option somewhere in your game
where you click change screen size to
whatever supported size
click ok then your screen resets but
having it on a hotkey can be a little
odd but
it gets the job done and that's it
that's it for the hot keys it's the only
thing we're supporting we could add more
hotkeys
notably the the guy who had his code
uh from that github the broken code he
had just like a plain
f in here which doesn't work you need
the sdl
versions it would if he was doing it
correctly he would have sdl
i think it's just f or lowercase f so
that is what he should have had
but i'm not using f anymore i'm just
using f
11. very good
sdlk for key i think underscore and then
whatever it is
so that's what the cases are there's no
case of characters these are
actually enums so you can see its value
there
as i hovered over it okay
so and then after that we go to part two
of
our main loop which is update the screen
so you might have seen up here that part
one oh actually i should probably have
this uh comment uh
right above this while loop because
actually the part one is check events
not while we're in the vents and doing
that loop so the part one is check
events
and the part two is go ahead and update
the screen
so we do it clear to clear what was ever
whatever was previously on the screen
this happens super fast you know 60
frames per second or more so
you clear the previous screen you do all
your updates render your new stuff
whatever you have once we have opengl
stuff in here maybe later we'll actually
say hey do this
if it moved if we had some kind of
moving logic with time we could like
spin a cube or something and we would
just add its new
location stuff here and and tell gl to
to hold that and then when we call the
swap window that is when it
displays this new stuff so with this
quick loop of clear update swap
it'll show all your stuff super quick
and it'll just keep doing that it'll
just stay in this loop keep checking
your keys keep rendering
and that's basically all we're doing
right now and then if you when you leave
if you exit that main loop it destroys
the main window and runs sdl quit which
are required to uh not leak
memory not
a honestly not a super big deal because
we're exiting right away and it's going
to
destroy them when it exits the program
but if you're running like
something where you have like a click a
button to open a window and the window
opens and then you close it but your
main program's still
still running you definitely want to be
cleaning up this good habit to get into
so let's go ahead and run this one last
time and do one last build with the new
changes i made while i was walking
through it there
hit f5 and we can see it
in action
alright so we'll go ahead and hit f11
here
full screen and now i'm gonna hit f10
just to confirm that the resize doesn't
do anything when i'm full screen
okay f 11 again hit f10
and yeah toggles between those two
supported sides the viewport stays the
same
and there we go so if for example let's
just say
what if we left this out what if we
don't do the swap window what if we
don't do the clear
just so you can see and of course you're
welcome to play around more stuff
but i just want to show you that
basically your viewport gets all
janky and uh you basically you'll just
be confused you don't see anything
because it's not swapping
to the new screen not swapping it's not
clearing they're not swapping to the new
screen
so if this is happening then you got
something going on with your clear and
swap window not being
in the right place there's a very common
error for people to run into
all the resize still works and
everything of course it's just all
janky and doesn't make any sense because
it's just not
swapping to that new code or to the new
screen i got some double comments in
here because that's what my
editor did all right well thank you for
watching hope you
uh have some excellent [ __ ] getting your
your stuff going it's really about the
same on windows and mac just the whole
linking is a little different i didn't
make any changes to the cmx he makes
still exactly the same as it was before
but with this cmake it actually should
work pretty fine on windows i think with
windows you might have to have like
a window in here or something and maybe
another header for the
native windows window
but it doesn't seem to be needed here
uh let me know if you have any questions
peace out guys